grüße aus der hauptstadt wir müssen ein
bisschen vorübergehend improvisieren
kriegen das aber gleich hin und können
das war vielleicht noch mal auf die
rahmendaten gucken also haushaltswoche
im deutschen bundestag das heißt politik
in zahlen beziehungsweise präziser noch
gesagt politik in euro es geht um den
ersten haushalt der ampelkoalition 460
milliarden euro wir haben es zu freunden
den beitrag schon mal gesehen wird er
umfassen in diesem jahr und das sind
ziemlich genau 100 milliarden euro
weniger als 20 21 es sind aber auch
etwas mehr als 100 milliarden euro mehr
als 20 19 also im letzten jahr vor
corona also jede menge geld das über
hier bewegt werden soll seitens der
koalition und das alles vor dem
hintergrund dass einerseits corona noch
nicht ganz weg ist obwohl das manche
gelegentlich zumindest behaupten und auf
der anderen seite wie auch noch den
krieg gegen die ukraine haben dessen
folgekosten und folgelasten auch auf
absehbare zeit noch nicht absehbar sind
das ist die eine seite der medaille
unter belästigt weil also mit fug und
recht sagen dass dieser haushalt den der
bundesfinanzminister hier in etwas mehr
als zehn zwölf minuten vorlegen wird mit
fug und recht wahrscheinlich nicht
ausreichen wird und wir haben
zusätzliche töpfe neben den 100
milliarden neuverschuldung die es geben
soll in diesem jahr beispielsweise mit
dem sogenannten sondervermögen
bundeswehr und außerdem ist jetzt schon
in gesprächen so genannte ergänzungs
haushalt über dessen höhe im moment
überhaupt noch gar nichts bekannt ist
also das ganze wird eine hoch
interessante angelegenheit und vor
diesem hintergrund freue ich mich dass
heute morgen zu diesem klima bei uns
sind gesine lötzsch stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und
haushaltspolitische sprecherin der
linksfraktion hier im deutschen
bundestag mit karsten klein ist bei uns
obmann der fdp fraktion im deutschen
bundestag her kleine die fdp wird mit
dem spruch politik die rechnen kann kann
man diesen haushalt verbuchen unter dem
slogan politik wie schön rechnen muss
nein also wir haben ja eine sehr klare
haushaltsaufstellung durchgeführt im
kernhaushalt erstmal das was sich die
koalition auch vorgenommen hat mit 457
mio euro da stecken investitionen in
höhe von 50 milliarden euro tränen auch
entlastungen übrigens auch nochmal
natürlich belastungen aufgrund der
korona krise allein für das bmg für das
gesundheitsministerium für die
wirtschaftshilfen über 25 milliarden
euro und jetzt natürlich in einer
besonderen lage aufgrund des coo ukraine
kriegs und den werden wir die
auswirkungen werden wir in einem
ergänzungs haushalt abbilden also ist
eigentlich sehr transparent was die
bundesregierung davor hat und deshalb
unterstützen werde es auch ich hab das
ja vor allem gefragt weil immer die rede
ist von 100 milliarden neuverschuldung
in diesem jahr aber faktisch sind es
mindestens 100 wahrscheinlich 150 mehr
und die werden halt nicht unter dieser
rubrik gefasst nur so habe ich gemeint
also dass die anderen dass sie die
anderen kosten nicht vertuschen oder
verheimlichen was auch gar nicht ginge
das habe ich noch nicht mal gemeint
sondern die frage ist warum sagt man
nicht von vornherein wir verschulden uns
in diesem jahr nicht um 100 sondern
eigentlich um 250 milliarden dass meine
frage na ja wir haben jetzt eine
besondere situation die den blick
geschärft hat bei der bundeswehr wir
haben da viel versorgen ist aus den
vergangenen jahren 16 jahre indem wir
die bundeswehr unter gespart haben und
dafür wird jetzt in sondervermögen in
höhe von 100 milliarden ich denke
sprechen sie an aufgesetztes wird mit
verschuldung finanziert ja da muss
natürlich geteilt werden das ist klar
aber das hat mir den kernhaushalt und
mit den projekten der koalition erstmals
auch nichts zu tun und die andere summe
die sie genannt haben die steht ja
bisher noch nicht fest wir wissen noch
nicht was im ergänzungs haushalt alles
abgebildet werden muss
[Musik]
geben sie mir die chance meine fische
geben sie mir ich kleine chance eine
frage zu stellen würde nämlich sagen sie
sind eine erfahrene haushälterin ich
weiß sie waren auch vorsitzende im
haushaltsausschuss sie haben jede menge
kritik an diesem haushalt an der
geplanten mittelverwendung bevor wir das
alles erörtern und bevor sie auch
tatsächlich dazu kommen das zu sagen ist
überhaupt realistisch in diesen zeiten
einen haushalt so zu gestalten dass er
wirklich wasserfest ist natürlich
aufgrund der aufgrund der einfach
aufgrund der lage die wir haben
natürlich muss man immer auf hat neue
herausforderungen auf situationen
reagieren
aber gerade das 100 milliarden
sonderprogramm ist ja das beste beispiel
dafür dass eben nicht auf neues reagiert
wurde denn alle diese projekte die jetzt
finanziert wurden die standen schon alle
im koalitionsvertrag oder finanziert
werden sollen es war nur kein recht
schnell dran und nun wurde der krieg
quasi genutzt der tag des krieges um zu
sagen jetzt brauchen wir 100 milliarden
euro extra und ich möchte auch dieser
legende widersprechen dass die
bundeswehr kaputtgespart wurde es ist
von jahr zu jahr mehr geld in die
bundeswehr geflossen und allein in der
zeit in der olaf scholz damals
finanzminister war sind 48,5 milliarden
euro mehr ausgegeben worden für die
bundesliga verglichen mit dem beginn
seiner tätigkeit als finanzminister also
das hat nichts mit neuen
herausforderungen und schuhen bällen
situation man hat einfach die
gelegenheit genutzt und man kann ja auch
sehen die aktie von rheinmetall die ist
gestiegen und zwar innerhalb von 100
tagen um 100 euro als der
koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben wurde
stand sie bei 80 jetzt steht sie bei 180
das sollte uns doch zu denken geben was
würden sie denn machen in dieser
situation also wichtig ist dass wir
wirklich unser sozialsystem auch stärken
damit die bedrohung der menschen
abgebaut wird und wir haben ja ich muss
auch der wieder behauptung widersprechen
dass alles was im koalitionsvertrag
steht abgebildet wird ganz im gegenteil
die armut steigt die
kindergrundsicherung die versprochen
wurde ist nicht im haushalt abgebildet
und ein krieg zu beenden dass es nicht
möglich durch bewussten christian haase
der haushälter der unionsfraktion sagt
das ganze sehr blendwerk und
augenwischerei und sagte auch irgendwie
erwartet wenn ja noch mal 140 bis 150
millionen plus sondern der bundeswehr
ich habe gerade auch schon gesagt das
wäre nach 20 1920 21 danach geht es
falsch nach 215 milliarden in 20 21 eine
weitere rekordverschuldung ich
unterstelle jetzt mal einfach auch dass
sie diesen begriff nicht im umlauf haben
wollen wer also wir sind ja in zwei
doppel großen herausforderungen zwei
krisen die korona krise sie haben das zu
recht gesagt ist ja noch nicht zu ende
corona ist noch da hat auswirkungen und
wir sind jetzt in dieser
auseinandersetzung in diesen
verbrecherischen krieg in der ukraine
und dann muss die bundesregierung
handeln und man könnte jetzt lange
ausführen was in der vergangenheit
schief gelaufen ist dass die bundeswehr
aus der substanz gelebt hat aber fakt
ist dass wir jetzt handeln müssen das
tun wir mit dem 100 milliarden programm
und ich glaube die friedenssicherung für
unsere bürgerinnen bürger hat eine hohe
priorität das ist ein nachhaltigkeits
ziel der un frieden sichern und das
machen wir auch mit diesem
sondervermögen und deshalb hoffe ich
doch dass alle fraktionen auch diesen
besonders von mücken zwischenhalt ein
paar minuten haben wir ja noch deswegen
werde ich auch für oft ziele und
prioritäten und möchte gleich nochmal
können nicht gekommen ich will einfach
noch mal ein bisschen bei dieser
haushalts konstruktion bleiben also dem
beispielsweise die frage wann wollen sie
denn diesen das sondervermögen
einbringen dass wir reden jetzt vier
tage über den über diesen haushalt der
schon 100 milliarden neue schulden
vorsieht wann wollen sie den ergänzungs
haushalt einbringen und wie soll der
dann diskutiert werden einfach das
verfahren interessiert mich jetzt mal
weil weil sie vorhin von transparenz
gesprochen also die grundgesetzänderung
die die sich jetzt in der in den
verhandlungen auch vor allem mit der
union wir brauchen die union für diese
grundgesetzänderung dass die union auch
ihre verantwortung übernimmt und wir
wollen die bundesregierung will den
ergänzungs haushalt auch so früh wie
möglich einbringen aber jetzt ist ja der
blick noch nicht scharf was da drin
stehen muss an humanitäre hilfe
natürlich auch an auswirkungen im
wirtschaftlichen bereich an
entlastungspaket
das soll aber deutlich vor abschluss des
haushaltes im haushaltsausschuss
erfolgen so dass wir im
haushaltsausschuss auch darüber
eingehend beraten können das wird
wahrscheinlich anfang mitte april seien
aber genaues datum steht noch nicht ok
das verfahren ist ich kann das verfahren
nicht akzeptieren überhaupt nicht also
es ist ja so dass die zeit sowieso schon
sehr knapp ist und wenn jetzt ein
haushalt heute diskutiert wird bzw die
ganze woche der dann gar keinen bestand
haben wird dann ist das natürlich auch
eine vereinbarung des parlaments und
insbesondere des haushaltsausschusses
und ich wollte noch kurzen wort sagen zu
der einbeziehung der union wir als linke
stehen jetzt einer großen opposition
gegenüber koalition wir sind hier die
opposition einer großen koalition die es
noch nie gegeben hat und zwar grüne spd
fdp spd und cdu die haben sich alle
verein zu diesem großen projekt
grundgesetzänderung für die aufrüstung
und das ist etwas was ich überhaupt
nicht akzeptieren kann aber das haben ja
die wähler zu verantworten dafür kann er
jetzt nichts ich meine es ist ein
resultat von einem wahlergebnis das ist
richtig das ist richtig aber die union
ist ja auch in der opposition und ohne
not hat sich die ampelkoalition in die
geiselhaft der union begeben ausgaben
das wird er anders sehen ausgaben sind
das eine neue schulden sind auf der
einen seite auf der anderen seite habe
ich gelesen dass sie mit 17 milliarden
mehreinnahmen rechnen in diesem jahr
also als ursprünglich veranschlagt wo
nehmen sie den diesem optimismus er denn
wir wissen die krise ist ja lange noch
nicht vorbei und auch die folgen die
diese auch beispielsweise der krieg
gegen die ukraine ausgelöst hat ihnen
überhaupt noch nicht absehbar wo kann
man das schon sagen dass wir in diesem
jahr 17 milliarden mehr im einnahmen
durch steuern vor allem auch haben
werden im haushalt verfahren ist ja so
dass die steuereinnahmen aufgrund der
projektion jetzt im januar erstellt
worden sind wir werden ja im haushalts-
prozess oder während des haushalts
prozess die steuerschätzung im mai haben
und die wird natürlich wie immer über
die bereinigungssitzung dann auch
nachgezogen im haushalt und dann auch
nachjustiert
das ist klar dass aufgrund super in
kriegs- wir wirtschaftliche verwerfungen
erleben werden dass man dann
entsprechend auch berücksichtigen müssen
eben auch in dem ergänzungs haushalt und
deshalb ist es auch wichtig die
alternative wäre ja nur gewesen dass wir
keinen haushalt einbringen ich glaube
dass wir die schlechtere signal gewesen
und deshalb ist es gut dass man jetzt
die auswirkungen dieser relativ
kurzfristig wir sehen jetzt nicht mal
vier wochen in diesen schlimmen konflikt
dass wir die jetzt nachziehen parallel
zum haushaltsverfahren mit einem
ergänzungs haushalt ist auch ein
transparentes verfahren die alternative
wäre gewesen dass man das mit einer
bereinigung vorlage gelöst hätten also
mit einem antrag praktisch im
haushaltsausschuss für die bürgerinnen
und bürger vielleicht dann
verständlicher das wäre intransparent
und deshalb machen wir das jetzt über
eine ergänzung zu hause und ich glaube
das ist eine sehr gute mann dann müssen
sie vom dogma keine steuererhöhungen
abrücken wir haben zwei leitplanken das
eigene ist erstens die grundgesetzliche
schuldenbremse gilt und wir waren auch
keine steuern wir sind ein
hochsteuerland in europa und das sind
die leitplanken für diese
bundesregierung haben wir die frage war
wann sie von lesung doch mal abdrücken
müssen weil sie die schuldenbremse sagen
sie gilt aber sie wird ja auch in diesem
jahr schon wieder unterlaufen
beziehungsweise sehens ausgesetzt aus
gutem grund muss man ja sagen und der
grund könnte nächstes jahr ja genauso
noch gelten im grundgesetz verankerte
schuldengrenze lässt die hat diese
notsituation die ausrufung zu wenn sie
begründet ist dieses jahr ist sie
begründet und deshalb werden an die
notsituation auch feststellen und
darüber hinaus sehe ich aktuell
überhaupt keine veranlassung über
steuererhöhungen zu sprechen sie wollen
eben schon reagieren prompt ja natürlich
also wenn von hochsteuerland die rede
ist dann muss man fragen für wen und
gerade das diw das deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung hat uns wieder mal
vorgerechnet dass in keinem land arbeit
zu hoch besteuert wird und vermögen so
niedrig und da muss man ran und meiner
auffassung ist unsere auffassung als
linke wir müssen endlich die
superreichen unserem land besteuert und
nicht weiter die klientel der fdp
schützen also keine gefahr so ruhig also
ich glaube wer sich die verteilung
anschaut weiß das natürlich
leistungsfähigen in deutschland auch am
extremsten zur kasse gebeten werden die
tragen die hoch lassen und auch zu recht
unseres gesellschaftssystems sehr
solidarisch und wir sind gegen die
vermögenssteuer weil die vor allem den
mittelstand damit die arbeitsplätze
trifft das führt genau zum gegenteil von
dem was die linke den menschen
verspricht nämlich zu einer
verschlechterung der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der arbeitsplätze
und damit zum arbeitsplatzabbau das
wollen wir nicht wir wollen
sozialversicherungspflichtige
arbeitsplätze und deshalb ist eine
vermögenssteuer definitiv das falsche
mittel gegen reden ja es geht ja nicht
darum vermögenssteuer ich wollte noch
mal richtig stellen was die
augenscheinlich jetzt nicht wahrhaben
wollten arbeit wird sehr hoch besteuert
und vermögen wird zu gering besteuert
und das müssen wir ändern und die
menschen gerade die mittelschicht wird
in einer weise belastet dass sie stöhnt
und ächzt und dass sie dringend dringend
entlastet werden muss und dafür hat die
fdp nichts getan und wo das ausscheiden
war nicht tun wollen also erstens glaube
ich ist es in so einer krise wichtig
dass wir vermögen das sind substanz der
unternehmen nicht noch besteuern und
damit das den fortbestand von
unternehmen erschweren den geht es schon
schwer genug das ist mit uns nicht zu
machen die linke hat ein anderes konzept
ist in ordnung und zweitens will ich
darauf hinweisen dass wir am anfang des
jahres schon ein entlastungspaket mit
heizkostenzuschuss auch mit einem
zuschuss grad für bedürftige beschlossen
haben wir haben einen übergangszeitraum
für das für das kinder chancen geld
geschaffen also ich glaube dass diese
koalition sehr ambitioniert und auswärts
zielgerichteter unterwegs ist wie wenn
im ergänzungs haushalt da auch nochmal
nachschärfen haben auch den
heizkostenzuschuss er jetzt noch mal
angehoben also ich glaube es ist nur
mehr zu behaupten dass wir die sozial
schwachen und diesen banden stücke
ketten und es kommen möglicherweise
weitere entlastung zusammen da hätte ich
jetzt tonka gefragt was er denn da die
kommission die wie ihr tag da aus den
drei koalitionspartner wie bhatti
fortgeschritten ist konsum zu helfen
naja ich glaube man muss man muss
einfach mal aufhören dass erstens die
mehrwertsteuerabsenkung die die union
fordert europarechtswidrig ist die ist
nicht möglich denn das ist nicht
zulässig auf europäischer ebene auf
benzin einen niedrigeren
mehrwertsteuersatz zu erheben ansonsten
diesen zwei vorschläge jetzt auf dem
tisch der einer von der spd eine von der
fdp da ist mir intensiv in der debatte
wir haben den tank rabatt vorgeschlagen
es gibt einen anderen entlastungs
vorschlag und ich glaube die koalition
wird wie ich das letzte mal auch
beweisen dass wir da zu einer guten
lösung kontrolle gekriegt noch einen
satz und wir können sagen wie sie die
wenn sie die möglichkeit hätten die
bürgerinnen und bürger die lasten einer
staatlichen preiskontrolle wir brauchen
keine steuererleichterung für die
konzerne in anderen ländern wird das
gemacht in italien in griechenland und
daran sollte man sich orientieren in
griechenland ist ein christdemokrat dran
der sagt wir brauchen hier die deckelung
der preise und das ist der richtige weg
schnelle runde heute morgen wie
jedenfalls kommt sowieso vor sie müssen
auch schon rein gehen das dürfen sie
jetzt auch eine frau lötet vielen dank
dass wir heute morgen hier waren auch
ihnen herr klein dass sie heute morgen
hier gewesen sind von euch doch jetzt
ganz munter den austausch